[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about the
best practices for community risk
reduction we have any okay owning us on
the show hello hello thank you so much
for coming on the show associated I'm
very excited thank you me too yes we're
very grateful that we were introduced to
you by Mike margulies and psychedelic
seminars and your talk that you did with
this man I'll leave from maps that was a
very very powerful conversation that you
two had and I'm really grateful that we
were able to learn more about your work
and invite you on to the show here we
are now and your background super
interesting Annie oak is a partner at
take three presents which is a San
Francisco based event production company
that orchestrate speak experiences to
catalyze personal and society evolution
through the production of private
immersive art and music events with a
focus on health and safety for
participants she's also the founder of
women's visionary Congress which since
2007 showcases women who work with
non-ordinary states of consciousness
activists healers researchers artists
and spiritual leaders all these links
can be found below to take three
presents the visionary Congress and even
dance safe org which we'll be talking
about soon all right Annie let's start
things off with this big history
perspective on civilization we find
ourselves as stewards of Earth what is
your current take on the state of human
I'm feeling optimistic today I think
that people have a sense that we need to
come together for a common purpose I
think that people are focusing on a more
inclusive including as many voices as
possible in public discourse on
addressing serious issues like climate
change and social equality human and
civil rights I'm feeling good I'm
feeling good about our potential to
evolve and take care of each other I
love that and what would you say is one
of the core principles that can help
people have that good discourse and come
together to tackle these pressing
challenges that we face sense of common
purpose a sense that we need to look out
for one another a sense that we're all
in this together collectively as your
immediate community and your larger
community here in San Francisco we've
got some issues that we really need to
address collectively as a city here and
it's true in all places and then we we
have obviously taken quite a bit of time
to unpack the importance of meditation
and psychedelics in these in this
ability to feel that common sense of
purpose here on earth well what would
you say are some of the best ways to get
to that common sense of purpose and
taking care of each other
figure out who your community is who is
your community what group of people do
you feel most kinship with how does that
community show up for and take care of
one another when things get tough and
how do you make connections to other
communities outside your own interesting
is the power of the connections within
your community and nourishing those and
then also from community to community
and extending the kinship to like the
global village yes yes yes okay Annie
how did you become who you are today
talk tell us about your journey leading
up to this this radical risk reduction
that you know well I've been a member of
different kinds of communities I was
always a really big fan of art and music
festivals when I was a kid really I
started going to Grateful Dead shows and
saw the kind of deadhead community that
grew up around those shows people really
took steps to look after one another and
had a sense of kinship and a sense of
really just looking after one another
and especially in chaotic music festival
environments also have really
appreciated and enjoyed the rainbow
family they've been looking after taking
care of one another for many years teach
us more about the rainbow family it's a
it's a community of people who've been
having large gatherings since the 1960s
there are no designated leaders they
often do it at you know large parks and
public spaces they survived for many
years of course there's the Burning Man
community
I've been going every year since 1996
I've learned a lot of lessons I have
very year yes every single year figure
it so your 23rd year I believe so
yeah other people have been going for
years not just me you know there
community of people have been going
there for a long time but it's been a
good place to learn about that community
and learn how to do you know I ran a
Burning Man camp for a couple years and
I learned a lot from that community so
you know different communities certainly
the sex-positive community here in San
Francisco I've been here in town in this
city for about 20 years and I was a
board member of the Center for sex and
culture the play party community and the
sex-positive communities have all done a
lot for risk reduction too and it's also
when I wouldn't when you're teaching you
about your journey I'm I'm actually
realizing that it makes total sense that
you became who you are because of all
the different stimuli that led you to
two events that led you to also that led
you to like things like Burning Man and
things like seeing how people
communicate people take care of each
other that seems to be you know makes a
lot of sense about you know how you got
to where you are today
so then how did it how did the
transition or this moment happen for you
where you were like okay well I've been
learning a lot about the best community
guidelines and practices how do I then
take a startup production organization
that focuses on this overdose moment the
moment for you well I'm a journalist by
training
science reporter by avocation I was in
the early 2000s covering a lot of
conferences and gatherings that talked
about the healing potential of
psychedelics I couldn't help but notice
that a lot of these events there were
mostly men speaking and not a whole lot
of women and I thought well that's funny
because I know a whole lot of women who
are researchers and healers and
activists and artists and spiritual
leaders who were really gifted and
had some really great ideas and it just
felt like they weren't getting their
voices hurt so I you know my personal
philosophy is if you want to change the
world throw a better party right yeah
yeah so I threw a party and it was the
first woman's visionary Congress in 2007
almost 100 people showed up we heard
from 23 amazing women it was open to
people of all genders and always has
been some men spoke later we included
transgendered people and it was it was a
success I think by 2008 we had formed a
nonprofit called the women's visionary
Council and we were producing events all
over the US and Canada our next event is
going to be in Oakland
June 14th to 16th you can read about it
on the visionary congress.org website so
we gathered a lot of information about
best practices health and safety from
that community of women especially the
elders we really made a point of making
it multi-generational so that
information could be passed from one
generation to the next as is done in
many traditional societies right so in
addition to holding an annual Women's
Congress and salons and gatherings in
the US and Canada we started to do a
series of Risk Reduction workshops where
we taught what we consider to be the
three most important drug safety skills
how to properly use naloxone or narcan
to prevent opioid overdose how to
properly use a milligram scale so that
you don't or other people don't overdose
by ingesting too much of something and
finally how to use reagent testing kits
that are available online to make sure
that you know what you're taking and
that you don't inadvertently poison
yourself by taking an adulterated
substance
yes and then that's dance safe is the
one that helps provide these reagent
testing kits they do dance safe is a
non-profit they've been providing these
reagent testing kits on their website
for many years and they provide reagent
testing services at many festivals and
events they're great people dance safe
door big shout out big shout out okay
okay and then this and you know dance
safe is one of the components you have
so many of these components for your
best community practices for for Risk
Reduction so let's let's let's talk
about you know you gave these really
cool workshops at the women's visionary
Congress and it was really cool hearing
about those plus the the vision that you
have for for for seeing more especially
female leaders step forward and be able
to voice their their thoughts about how
to best how to best have work with
showcase the experiences of non-ordinary
states of consciousness this is very
very important and now that sort of led
you to then doing take three presents
okay and then take three so the women's
visionaries around 2007 take threes
around 2013 and then you guys are
getting these rolling a couple of these
events a year leading up to about a
thousand people per event and these are
you know multi day-long events and
they're popular largely because it
creates a safe container safe space for
people to experience these altered
states of consciousness or even just
play and all this type of stuff so yes
please teach us about how this kind of
got started and then we'll get into
those best practices well I ran a large
Burning Man camp for a few years learned
a few things about that started a
teahouse called the full circle tea
house as I saw at Burning Man that there
weren't enough spaces that weren't bars
where people could just come and
and hydrate and lie on soft pillows and
drink a nice cup of tea and have
conversations yeah and so I you know
Bernie man was kind of my Academy I
learned how to build a camp build a tea
house recruit crew do big art projects
and I got together with a couple of
other friends who also had some similar
experience running big Burning Man camps
running art and music these camps and
and we thought you know we know a lot
why don't we throw a little party of our
own and we did and people loved it and
that was back in 2013 and and now we we
hold these private art music parties I
think they're unique in certain ways and
and certainly a focus on health and
safety I think is attractive to people
we have also really supported a
community of artists which is the most
important thing I think we help raise
money to create good art and help
support the community of artists here in
the Bay Area acknowledge their work
create opportunities for people to
create art and then create a safe
container so that people can do really
fun wild art and be acknowledged for
that and this is now thousands of people
over over like dozen or so events and
it's just crazy thinking about all the
people that have been able to experience
this in a place that you've crafted
through your experience that enables
this to happen and I really I really
want to people to get an idea of some of
the things you mentioned like these
practices of like you know like a tea
house and you you have like snuggling
and an art and music and dance but even
also swimming so there's a wide array of
things here for people to experience and
play with and test and then sometimes
people have altered states of
consciousness
it happens I think that the desire to
change one's consciousness is an innate
human trait do believe this we do it in
lots of different ways not just through
substances yeah every night you go to
sleep hopefully and you dream that is
also an altered state of consciousness
that's right our dream lives but our to
music bring us into an altered state
being outside in nature yeah
swimming and other athletic you know
active things snuggling with people you
really like you know all of this
dancing lots of things do right yeah
lots yeah and you're right it's
definitely not just substance it's
substances it's so many of these other
things you listed are such profound ways
of shifting our innate you it's
interesting they should point out that
you think that we have it like a
proclivity to go towards those altered
states it's very interesting yeah yeah
every morning I get up and I drink a
strong cup of coffee I love that altered
state yeah right yeah yeah yeah that's
right that caffeine is yeah it's brought
in exogenously into the body to change
the state yeah yeah but we don't
typically think of caffeine and coffee
as an or is it just a state change of
consciousness state changers I think
that's that's an important point then
this is so important these are the best
practices for health and safety that
that you've figured out there's so many
powerful ones here I'm very excited to
get to these and and and you you taught
you taught me this too that this is not
just you know it has to be like this for
every community you make it clear that
adapt to your communities how these best
fit and best work which i think is very
important let's start off with this
identifying and empowering leaders yes
so whatever community you're part of I
think it's really important that you
decide what your values are what are
your values as a community you want
people to be treated with fairness
gentleness great-state those values and
then figure out who are the leaders in
your community who are the most
respected people in your community and
how are you going to empower them to
uphold those values right because
conflict disagreements miscommunication
is all part of the human condition hurts
a lot of communities figure out how
you're going to address that in ways
that reflect your own values usually so
that identifying empowering leaders has
a lot to do with having a community
discourse around shared values yeah and
then I and then when you find people
that are able to maybe take leadership
roles maybe they have the time and they
have developed a long period of of
building up the skills that make them a
good leader then you can empower them
that way then this is cool documents
setting expectations yeah if you part of
a community you want to say here are
community values I think that people
should be respected I think they should
be heard I think that they they have a
right to be treated with fairness
remember your community value is it's
good to write it down and say here are
values if you violate these agreements
somehow let's think about a process
about how we're going to address that
because you know like I said conflict is
part of the human condition so you kind
of plan for it right and and and also
find ways to uphold a sense of community
harmony and shared values as well right
by laying out you know perhaps on paper
perhaps if your fears is an oral
tradition however you do it
what your values and expectations are
and then what might happen if people
don't uphold those expectations and who
are your community leaders who will help
people to
understand what the expectations are
this is describing all kinds of
traditional communities and
non-traditional communities right it's
basic process yeah and when you when you
document the values it then becomes
easier for the community to be able to
see it in experience and then also the
kind of like it becomes in a sense of
kind of like a judicial processes as
well for what we're about to talk about
with consent and with all these other
things so that way there's no questions
really it's kind of like we already had
this written down that the Sioux these
were the steps oh yeah yeah exactly then
this was this was very new to me the
invitation only with sponsors so you've
built up your your events by those that
attend the events can sponsor someone
else so like I could sponsor wrong and
then I would be responsible for if Ron
made a mistake and did something wrong
so that way it's a very kind of like a
tight closed loop with who you bring in
you have to make sure they're good yeah
exactly it's an accountability system
right if if you invite me to a party and
you say you can come to this party as my
guest I'm responsible for you and
everything you do at that event I will
probably be on my best behavior because
I don't want to make you look bad right
and I want to abide by the agreements of
the community and so it's a powerful way
to hold people accountable for the
people they invite for themselves you
know it's an old idea right my favorite
example of those are sex parties and a
lot of the sex party communities around
the world you know this is part of many
of those communities structure you have
to vouch for somebody vouch for them is
a good person and then you're
responsible for the people you invite
that's a pretty simple idea really yeah
yeah I love the accountability that that
creates that's a very great point it's
almost as though
when you're in in in someone's home and
and your friend your guests through a
friend that you need to like clean up
your dishes and like you know and
there's these types of basic things in
the house otherwise your friend looks
bad if they prot you and you're not
cleaning up after you exactly yeah yeah
interesting and then I'm sure that that
also makes it of course then if since
there are these altered states of
consciousness this is even more
important than just dishes this is on a
whole new level with consent as well
actually when you said this to me I
thought that this was quite unique
because we're so addicted to technology
we're so addicted to social media we're
so addicted of talking about everything
consuming that digital stream of
consciousness that when you said that we
don't do press that we don't do social
media that I was like interesting okay
well there's a value to immediacy of
experience and there's also a value in
being circumspect about all the details
of magic that you want to create right
and so you know we have our own rules
about how people can discuss these
gatherings and I think by and large that
works pretty well I think that certain
communities can can create their own
private social media platforms a lot of
communities do it on slack for instance
or other apps where they have a whole
social media world that's private yeah
to that community and I think that's a
really interesting model closed groups
closed lists sure they're closed
Facebook groups as well you know I mean
people have different ways of
approaching this
yeah no interesting and the whole no
press thing is also interesting too I
think sometimes you learn these lessons
the hard way I'm a reporter by training
and I think there's power to creating
your own story and not necessarily allow
it to be interpreted by others and I
think many of us have learned hard
lessons about that many many people have
yeah and then you don't serve alcohol to
so you
there's altered states of consciousness
but you were actually listening to me
some very impressive figures about
alcohol increasing aggression and and
and and kind of hurting the consent
conversation so kind of making it harder
to interpret assent didn't that type of
stuff yeah I think alcohol is a tricky
drug obviously a lot of people use it's
easily accessible etc pretty much all of
the entertainment industry is built on
the the model of alcohol sales you know
to support clubs or event that sort of
thing I think we made a decision it take
three that we weren't going to serve or
sell alcohol and I think that served us
really well I think personal use in
personal quantities is is a fine you
know I think it's doesn't impact a
community the same way that running a
lot of bars does add an event or free
bars like at Burning Man for example I
like a cold beer on a hot day like I am
NOT a prohibitionist with alcohol I just
think that when you make it the center
of your event by having a bar
then it encourages people to drink more
alcohol often doesn't mix well with
other substances dehydrates people yeah
hard to stay hydrated and therefore
happy cheerful and healthy in heat
especially it certainly complicates
consent issues it makes people more
aggressive and less aware of personal
space and and it's nice to be able to
offer environments without it that's why
I started tea house yeah and the full
circle tea house that I started at
Burning Man does serve take three events
and and it's now run by a collective
based in Auckland shout out to the
collective yep if you want to hire them
for your event let me know be happy to
introduce you yep you know this is a
this is a cool principle that I think of
many people when we experience our
normal day-to-day lives we see so much
alcohol consumption as a normality in
cannabis consumption now as a normality
so tobacco consumption as a normality so
to be able to have a counter cultural
perspective to that I think is extremely
extremely important what are the altered
states of consciousness that potentially
maximize the Society's potential towards
unity and not drive us potentially
further away in some cases
what about reagent testing you were
teaching us about dance safe earlier and
what is that what does it mean to take a
substance and and how do we know that
this testing is is high-efficiency that
we know that how do we get the read out
that it's the right substance teach us
about this process well there are
different ways to test substances the
the most common way is to do reagent
testing you can buy reagent tests via
the dance a website you can buy them
online used to be able to buy them on
Amazon I think they just took them off
Amazon and what would it look like to
have a read what does that look like a
reagent tested so the reagents are or
chemicals that you add to a sample of a
substance that you want to test so like
a little piece of psilocybin or though
you take a little piece of substance
you're not quite sure what it is or
maybe you think you know and you want to
make sure it's not adulterated and you
put it in a little ceramic dish or on a
plate and then you add some of the
reagent and different reagents will test
for different substances or or or a
substance you're particularly testing
for and there's a color chart and that
reagent will turn your sample a certain
color and that color will indicate the
presence of that substance so you can
both confirm what you think it is God
with that substance and also see whether
perhaps it's turning another color and
it's the substance you didn't expect it
to be yeah the important theory thing
here is that fentanyl synthetic opioid
very dangerous causes overdose and
sometimes death in very small quantities
has been found in many street drugs yeah
and many counterfeit pharmaceuticals and
it's important to encourage people to
test what it is they have so that they
don't inadvertently overdose or poison
themselves or others it's really
important and dance safe does this
testing at many events and it's really
important that people learn about it and
learn how to use these kits or go to a
dance safe booth at an event there are
symbiosis there are lots of big events
and test your substance make sure that
you're not inadvertently poisoning
yourself or other people
that's a really scary one that if yeah
if we if we if people can eventually die
or have serious health issues from not
testing substances this is this is a
very very important one I'm curious a
little bit more on the on does dance
they've have this for like LSD and MDMA
like which do you know if it's all subs
all substances or contests for a lot of
substances with their reagent kits and
there's a lot of information on their
website upset about this interesting
okay
okay and it's a pretty clear like if
it's this color all the way on the side
it's 100 percent right if it's way over
here on this other color it's totally
wrong it's not that well nothing's 100%
but it's um but it but you can you can
do some pretty accurate testing mask gas
chromatograph testing you know
chromatograph you you there they're
different ways to test various
substances and there are more
sophisticated pieces of equipment that
are used by commercial laboratory
researcher so they're you know there are
a lot of different ways that one could
test these substances yeah yeah yeah it
will be great when these experience has
become more and more common to be able
to go to the locations that are near
your communities to go and test with
very high fidelity now what about this
is this was a big part the culture of
consent this is a massive we we've sat
down with Aurora quenelle Moore who's a
major proponent of enthusiastic consent
culture and we really hugely you know
KOCO Mackenzie who's doing a really
powerful work in the space as well and
this has become a reoccurring a
super-important conversational piece now
which especially during the me to
movement all this type of stuff and it's
it's um it's it's a really big awakening
that we're having with this with this
process and this is a huge part of your
documentation in your community values
that this is the way that we do things
like we
it has to be a hell yes a hell yes hell
yes
make sure yes is a hell yes yeah it's
affirmative consent right yeah yeah
don't say you know is a good rule of
thumb right yeah yeah so yeah I think I
think it's we certainly do all we can do
to support a culture of consent and and
it's not just sexual consent you know
like be careful with like roughhousing
with people you know don't don't
inadvertently get too rough when you're
playing with folks like be you know
check in with folks before you touch
them a roughhouse with them
don't dose people with substances
without their consent of course that's a
big one
that's I mean their basic ethics right
this is a basic ethical you know
approach to caring for other folks
no no I'm curious what your perspective
is on like if you know if you are doing
some but both parties are interested in
what it's occurring and maybe one is you
know and like you're you're like you
said don't roughhouse too much maybe ask
like can I go a little bit can you would
you be interested in me going a little
bit rougher whatever it may be
yeah in the sense is that typically it
so it's usually better to ask for you
know for permission rather than
forgiveness and in in like a consensual
environment for like physical
physicality definitely and and don't
assume that because you might have given
me consent to to do a certain thing that
that extends to other things like ask
for consent along the way like I can say
Allen you know is this okay and you'll
go yeah that's great and then I'll and
then I'll go is this okay right so just
checking interview you know with people
to see like like you know don't assume
it's a steady state
so it's a it's a moving series of
negotiations yes yes yes yes and then um
also I want you to teach us about your
systems for for reporting and for the
violations that occur so yeah teach us
about how to handle this well well I
mean every community is gonna do this
differently it's got to reflect your own
community values that you've agreed upon
like whatever that said about use our
but for communities that I'm part of
best practices I really like the idea of
forming an in-house health and safety
team yeah for your events let's say
you're producing a big party and you've
decided that you want to have some
safety teams at the party you go as far
as to have your own medics and
counselors we have a number of safety
teams we we do hire professional medics
which i think is a great idea you know
have some medical people on hand to do
check-ins with people or to take care of
first aid emergencies if someone's
really hurt and they need transport to a
hospital make sure you have a sober
driver you know standing by to do that I
mean this is really basic stuff right
this is not rocket science in addition
to that I think it's a great idea to
have an in-house crew of health and
safety people I really like the Ranger
model right it's an old idea it's not
just something Burning Man came up with
although their of course the Burning Man
Rangers but you know there's a long
tradition of Park Rangers or or other
kinds of Rangers that look out for
people in environments right so so our
events we have a crew of Rangers who who
patrol the event in pairs you know of
people 24/7 throughout the entire course
of the event and
and people know that they can go to them
for assistance advice help of any sort
and and then we have you know leaders of
each shift
you know those shifts are about six
hours long and we recruit those Rangers
from within our community and train
those people and then there's a subgroup
of those people who create a quiet space
inside our event and staff that space
and we recruit kind competent thoughtful
people who can think on their feet and
just provide that kind of community care
together with those teams the tea house
servers if there's a place that you know
you know the music loud it's late you're
tired you're having a great conversation
with someone you could say ah I just
need to sit down and hydrate take a rest
yeah won't we go to the tea house yeah
and just have a nice cup of tea and
continue this conversation right and
music festivals are there's nowhere to
find this type of stuff music festivals
is just you're either raging at the
stage or there's the porta-potties right
so that's why I started the tea house so
if if you're on the playa come find us
full circle tea house and camp soft
landing we're usually around 9:15
between B and D if you're a burner or a
tower you know WBC and take three events
we have the tea house present there's
some place you can go
I think a lot of risk reduction is
proactive ideally what do people run
into trouble with at a big raging
festival or event they're tired they're
dehydrated and they're lonely right so
if you can provide a social space where
people can fill up their water bottle
have a cup of tea maybe take a nap or
snuggle on soft pillows you know and
some nice people to talk to with the tea
bar or say nothing yes just sit down at
the tea bar have your nice cup of tea
take it all in take a little nap then go
back out and rage
right Wow just yeah just such a such a
very practical mentality to to having
more of these options available yeah and
having professionals available medics
and counselors this is so important
because we typically think of of how do
you meet how do you mediate how do you
do any of this mediation
well you mediate by having professionals
like you said that some of your
mediators are actually like certified
for dealing with cases of rape yeah so
what we do is we have a we recruit from
within our community people with special
skills for example I try to recruit
somebody for each of our events to lead
sobriety support groups right at our
events somebody who is themselves
supporting their own sobriety for
whatever reason right doesn't matter
really what so that if you want to come
to one of our events and be sober not
use anything you might be around other
people who maybe you're using cannabis
but you know into whatever it doesn't
matter there are groups on-site a couple
times a day that you can go to and get
support for your decision you know what
for whatever reason you're making it in
terms of mediators and counselors we
always have somebody 24/7 to step in and
it is a professional mediator and is
trained as a rape crisis counselor to to
step in and provide mediation and that
kind of counseling support immediately
on call so the Rangers know that they
have somebody like that you can come in
and provide that service in between
events we've recruited our own group of
mediators from within our community
again who understand our values who have
each training and media
or social workers or as counselors they
bring those skills with them and and we
consider complaints and incidents of
conflict in between our events or
perhaps we follow up on something that
took place during an event right so
there's a group of people who will
consider each of those cases make a
decision what to do should the person
who has violated consent be removed from
the invitation list is there is there a
series of steps we might ask them to do
to get counseling to attend groups to
educate themselves about consent a group
who makes those decisions are really
important for each community to create
in their own way because then conflict
is addressed it doesn't metastasize and
injure the community right a lot of
communities have been torn apart by
conflict so if you have a system a group
of people to carry out what are
agreed-upon community values protocols
for how they do that that are published
and understood then you can go a long
ways towards really healing the kind of
conflict that just happens within
communities and and not you know the
default is impunity right nothing
happens
people have hard feelings people are
hurt people are injured communities can
can really take action another thing I
will say is that is that these people
who will make decisions about conflict
are precious they're precious
community resources treat them like
precious resource
right do everything you can to prevent
them from burning out yeah it's a hard
job to our job I would suggest that the
group of people in your community who
are making decisions about how to deal
with conflict are separate from
group of people who let's call them case
managers sure let me say what I'm saying
so one group makes a decision about what
to do in a specific case let's say in
that case somebody has done something
that violates a community agreement the
case manager separate person yeah
we'll follow that case follow that
person make sure that they get the
counseling or support that they need
separate those two groups don't burn out
the group of people making the decisions
communities make this mistake all the
time that's a precious resource
interesting a case manager for community
guideline violations on a per cases for
case basis social workers do this you
know in a Social Work team there's a
group of people make a decision and then
the case managers right same thing I've
learned so much working with
professionals in our community who do
this and who are part of our mediation
team protect them they are a precious
resource people will cycle in and out of
this group identify the people in your
community you have the skill see if you
can create your own internal group to
reflect your own values more that you're
teaching us about this the more I'm
realizing that your community guidelines
need to be a part of every single
community really well there best
practices you know I mean they're
published on the wvc website under the
projects tab it's one of our projects
for community health and safety they're
just a whole list of best practices pick
and choose for what works for your
community what works for you what
reflects your values modify them if you
have new ideas feedback get in touch
with me I'm Annie it take three presents
calm that's that's an interesting point
two is that is that you adjust them to
your own community so these community
guidelines like you're like we're just
saying it was like these are really
powerful ones for a lot of people and
then for other people their communities
are going to take and maybe remove a
coupler add new ones and complement them
because some communities may be really
like rough play or whatever and then
they want to be explored just that in
some way but you know there's also yeah
there's old there's all different styles
of community to apply values and and
principal sets and documentation and and
and the proper of mediation teams all
this type of stuff is so interesting
even for sobriety we were talking about
that earlier just how important that is
for those that want the support that
typically don't get it and I'm imagining
these festivals now not having just
stage and porta-potties but rather I'm
imagining tea houses and sleeping areas
and and and guidelines Community
Guidelines post it around and you get
them via email beforehand and you like
have to read it and accept it yep this
type of stuff these are like yeah there
are these really complicated ideas you
know these are pretty simple ideas but
if you know communities want to embrace
what works for them modify them to suit
their own values it can really help to
promote harmony and to de-escalate
conflict and make people feel empowered
and also safe which is pretty big yeah
yeah this is actually full circles this
all the way back to your initial points
about unity and communities and and this
is a great way principle set to get us
to get us there
any this is such a pleasure I'm really
happy we're able to sit down to talk
about all of this and I want to ask you
a couple questions I would typically ask
on the way out of our shows one of the
first question that we like to ask is if
you think we're alone in the cosmos
hahahaha no I don't think we're alone in
the cosmos I think that were haven't
quite developed a technical capacity to
communicate with other beings and
entities in the cosmos I think that we
will I like to think it'll happen in my
lifetime I'm looking forward to it
yeah mm-hmm what we're gonna develop the
technical capacity to communicate with
the others I think we have received some
interesting signals from other parts of
the cosmos I mean that that photo of the
black hole was pretty cool the other day
right we are not alone in the cosmos or
roaches perhaps technologically behind
other beings in the cosmos in terms of
our ability to communicate interesting
and then do you think that this is a
simulation us right now no I I think
that this is a present moment and it's
not simulating anything it's a true
moment in time
and the the it's and maybe another way
to potentially phrasing rather than
there being like a false if it's a
simulation and it's like false it's not
real or whatever that it is still real
it's just that if it's a base reality or
not hmm yeah I think reality is the
subjective value right different people
experience reality differently our
experience of this moment is going to be
different from all you folks watching on
a web stream pray or discern so wherever
you are I hope you're enjoying this
conversation this moment in time out on
the net blessings to your experience
right and as it looks
that's a video stream for them and it's
in person for us so could easily look
simulated to on a video stream easily
any and the last question we like asking
on the show is what is the most
beautiful thing in the world
mmm the most beautiful thing in the
world is the capacity for love from all
beings
yeah capacity for love the capacity for
forgiveness capacity for kindness
capacity for mercy and for care yeah
whatever happens next you know those
things are are true and are upheld and
we'll all be in the moment together yeah
the so beautifully said we agree and we
believe in our future generations being
able to get us there
absolutely young people are so empowered
I have a lot of faith in in the younger
generations coming up behind us we make
every effort in all of our gatherings to
include people from all generations
especially it take three events because
a lot of the festival scene tends to
trend younger but including people of
all ages has really created a more of a
richness of experience in the passing
along of knowledge yes yes yes that
transgenerational wisdom any what a
powerful show on these best principles
and practices for community safety
health this is really powerful thank you
thank you for coming on and teaching us
thank you thank you yeah I appreciate
being here and thanks to everybody who's
been watching thank you for listening to
us today yes yes huge thank you to you
any huge thank you to everyone at home
we greatly appreciate you thank you so
much for tuning in and watching we would
love for you to let us know your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode go and share more of these
principles and practices Community
Guidelines and more people around you
for maximizing safety and health in our
communities also you know tweak them and
apply them at your will and also huge
shout out to Ron Vargas our producer and
director thank you so much Ronnie and
support the artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in our links are below
help us grow help us stay afloat and
support the artists in your communities
as well help them
sustain and grow and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon peace
[Music]
[Music]